and when i met my guru i really felt
loved unconditionally and what happened
was
i opened and then i became very attached
to his form and to being near him and to
looking at him into touching him and to
bringing him gifts and
breakfast in bed whatever just like you
do with your beloved
you want them to be happy as long as it
includes you
well i'll be happiest with somebody else
oh wonderful because i love you so much
see about unconditional love see how
quickly it gets you
but because of the particular game that
my guru was playing with me he kept
throwing me out all the time
he'd only let me see him for a couple of
minutes and then he'd say jiao
go split go somewhere else
and i at first got very offended
i mean can you imagine if you fall in
love with somebody and then you
you cross the ocean bringing fruit and
whatever you can bring
that you could possibly offer to your
beloved
and you've come this long way and you
feel a mixture of righteousness and
desire and
everything and he's all wrapped up with
your enlightenment and everything so you
can't get there fast enough and you get
there and you kneel down he looks at you
and he
pulls your beard hits you on the head
asks you one question and says ciao
you say zhao yeah
he let other people stay around him and
not me
so he obviously loved them more than he
loved me
terrible problem i got to hate the other
devotees so intensely
but then he took me through this trip
which most of you know that have read
any
stuff i've written and i'm just gonna
take you through because it's so
delicious as a teaching
even if you've heard it think of how
many times i've heard it
this was in the early 70s when a number
of
people like meera and danny and we were
with maharaja
llama syria we were kept in the back of
the
temple ashram we were paraded in
in the bus in the morning we got there
he'd be sitting outside we'd have darsh
we'd hang around him and
love him and he'd throw fruit at us and
you
just couldn't get you were drunk with
love and everything he said to anybody
applied to everybody and then after
about
i don't know five minutes or a half hour
he'd say jow and he'd throw us all in
the back where
we'd be fed we were known as only useful
for five things
drinking tea gossiping sleeping eating
and moving about
that was our practice so in the back of
the ashram that's all we do
and then late in the afternoon we'd all
be brought back just before the bus was
leaving
have another time together and then be
thrown out and in the course of the day
he'd call people up from the back there
was one woman who sang
beautifully so he'd call her up and say
sing and she'd sing it was like little
performing animals you know you wind up
an outcome
we were the westerners you wind up and
out you coming
so he had indians coming and they'd be
hanging out and he'd say you want to see
a westerner
you know perform and be brought forth
and
some of us were scholars and we'd be
scholarly and some of us were pundits
who could recite hindu
things and some of us could sing hindu
kirtan
and he'd bring us forth you know and i
was like a professor from harvard and
there i'd come i've fact i've been
thrown out was irrelevant to maharaji
you know
so then one day he called me up and i
come and each time you're getting called
you've been called
out of this mass of you know
unworthy people you've been chosen to go
up and be worthy
and so you rush up because you realize
this is going to be your chance to get
the juice this is it you know and you
run up and you kneel down
and you look up i mean this is all a
game you understand this is all
forms first when i went to india i
thought i'm not going to touch anybody's
feet what a bunch of you know
now i couldn't do it fast enough and
it's
i used to try to grab one of his feet
and then it would go under the blanket
quick
because and i think i'm not pure enough
i mean it was like
it's a whole routine you play out so i
go up and he'd look and he'd say
ram das love everyone
i'd say yes maharaja he'd say joe
see she go back and that was what you
got that day you'd sit there
love everyone boy i don't love everyone
i should love everyone
[Music]
the next day he called me up and got
caught in two days running
came up and he leaned way down he held
my beard and he said ramdas
this is in hindi rhyme dance
tell the truth yes maharaji
jiao so i was left that day with how
what a liar i was
i decided i'd really tell the truth
well he kept doing this each day he'd
alternate
was either love everyone or tell the
truth
and it took me about four or five days
because of my density before i realized
the peculiar predicament i found myself
in
that he was giving me two contradictory
instructions because the truth was i
didn't love everyone
so i thought about which one shall i do
and i thought you know what i always do
is i
love everyone even if it's not the truth
i make believe i love them i love you
oh yes we love each other oh it's okay i
love you
i thought maybe it'd be good to try
telling the truth
that'll be refreshing and as i looked at
all my guru by
my guru brothers and said i realized i
hated them all
because they all took me away from him
and i had spilled the beans about him in
the first place would be here now and
now i was set with all these
unworthy on you know people that were
hanging around taking his time
i mean they were nice people but i had a
good reason i mean i just didn't hate
them generally i
i'd find reasons for each one
you know that one was too arrogant and
that one had you know
after a week or two i was really i just
the truth was i found i didn't like
anybody
i even had a sign on my door do not
enter
now at the same time i was doing another
sadhana
another practice which was that maharaji
said rondas should not
touch money you know you make you can
interpret that at many levels
now i interpret that my my mind
shouldn't cling or fixate on money
that's that allows me to have a credit
card
but in those days i took it literally i
shouldn't touch money
so what i did was one of my friends my
group i would be a bag person
they'd carry my money so we get on the
bus they'd pay my bus fare
see that worked out fine until i got to
hate them all
now i was in a predicament because i
had nobody who i didn't hate
who i hadn't alienated to be my bag
person
now from the hotel to the temple is
eight miles
so what i found was i caught to the
position where there was a day
where everybody got on the bus and i had
no money to get on the bus
so i had to walk
all the way to the temple i walked
knowing what fun they were all having at
the temple
because they got there in about half
hour and it was going to be about three
hours for me
it was through the back woods and so i
was getting more and more angry i was
getting
furious and when i came over looking
down on the temple
i saw them all laughing and they were
all
hanging around maharaji and he's
obviously spent much more time with him
today than any other day
and i was full of loathing and hatred
and i
hated myself and felt so impure to even
walk into the temple
and i walked in and by then they had
just as i came down they were all
had their lunches uh they were sitting
on a porch with
leaf plates and their food
and i came in and they might have been
talking about me i don't know but one of
the people
who i especially despised
came up with a leaf plate of food and
offered it to me
and i took it and i threw it at him see
[Music]
i remember the moment very clearly i
mean that was uh
ha ha
[Laughter]
[Music]
um and i heard maharaji from across the
courtyard
ramdas
ramdas
and i looked over at him and i at that
moment i hated him too
right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and i went across the courtyard pissed i
mean i was
really angry and i sat down in front of
him
and i looked up at him and i was like
you know i
oh i was so my bones were aching you
know how that gets when you're really
constricted
and he looks at me says something
troubling you
[Laughter]
i said yeah yeah yeah
yeah what is it i said i hate all of
them
[Laughter]
and i said and i hate myself and he said
do you love me
[Applause]
and i looked at him
and it just fell apart
i opened and i started to sob absolutely
sob
i said i love you and he i was
sobbing and he went and he sent for milk
and he was pouring
milk down my throat and he was patting
me on the head and
i went through the whole catharsis and
all of that
and then he came up to me kind of nose
to nose he leaned over on his tucket
and he said i told you to love everyone
i said but you told me to tell the truth
and the truth is i don't love everyone
and he leaned forward and he said to me
ram das love everyone
and tell the truth
at that moment what i experienced were
two things first
was i experienced a coffin
in front of me in which who
i thought i was was in the coffin
who i thought i was was somebody whose
truth was that they didn't love everyone
and what he was describing to me was who
i would be
when i finished being who i thought i
was can you hear that is that
and the other thing was that at that
moment i turned and i looked over at my
fellow screw by sisters and brothers
and i saw that at one level i was
i had all this righteous indignation
about them
but one little flip of consciousness
and i saw how incredibly beautiful each
one of them was
and i loved them so deeply
jowl and that was the teaching
and i realized that since that time for
20 years
i have been learning that teaching
i have been letting and when i realize
is that when i
don't feel that love for another human
being
i hear maharaji saying ram does
love everyone and tell the truth
then he said to me afterwards he said
ramadas
give up anger
and i'll help you he didn't say
as i would say as a psychotherapist
let's work through your anger
he said give up anger
and i took that as a spiritual charge as
a message
and that when i experienced anger
instead of trying to figure out why i
experienced the anger which kind of
investing it i would just start to do
breathing
and rom and start to go into devotional
practice and just let go
even though the same angle would come
back up again
at one point i was studying with a very
beautiful man named anagorika menindra
he was a taravadin buddhist
teacher lovely lovely man
and i came to him one time
and i said to him menindriji
i am so angry because i had so much
anger in me
for so many years and keeping grudges
those deep things that always cut you up
every time that person's conscious
the thought of that person goes through
your head you constrict
and he said ramdas
don't hold on to what it's just old
karma running off
your anger is just old karma running off
and one of the traps that i saw that i
was caught in
was the trap of righteousness that i
used to justify my anger
but i saw that love freed me back
into the ocean and that anger didn't
and that i would rather be free than
right
and that's a scary and big one
and that if somebody does an abhorrent
action
i have to cultivate the capacity
to as kabir said and maharaja used to
quote kabir said
do what you do with another being
but never put them out of your heart
do what you do with another being but
never put them
out of your heart that is a total
prescription
for social activists
oppose stand up
defy confront
do what you do with another person you
stop their action
you may have to imprison that person so
that they don't hurt other people
you do what you must do but you do it
without closing your heart
and i don't mean the fraudulent oh i
didn't close my heart i mean really
the quality of do what you do but do it
always
in the presence of the beloved